we all enjoy hip-hop and rap music
and we celebrate the artists
and we know full well that a lot of
these artists have killed people
yet we celebrate them
why is it if a lot of these artists have
killed people we don't say anything
but then chris brown
assaults rihanna and the whole world
loses their [ __ ]
um which isn't obviously okay but i'm
just playing
i'm more of a country fan i know i have
my rap reactions those are just to be
funny
i'm more of a country type of girl but
um i think it's like the gynocentric
social order because like it's almost
like they see rappers as like going to
war in a way
because they really don't like mess with
like normal people like normally it's
just like people that are involved in
that stuff yeah not making it right but
it's almost like seen as like like a
battle or like war of like between these
two where like rihanna is a girl
and i think it's like gynocentric social
order
yeah go on i was just gonna say do we
think it would be different if it wasn't
random it was just like some random
woman no i think it oh i think i think i
think it'd be the same i'll be honest i
think it'll be the same
yeah i think so too i think it'd be the
same
i don't think it's because she's rihanna
i think it's because
she's a woman okay so arguably so we
know that
the rapper the baby you might not know
who he is do you know bob and brother
you know who he is i don't know what
happened with him but i know who he is
so
apparently he's apparently deleted some
people
off of you know he's killed some people
um no one said [ __ ]
and then he made a homophobic comment
everyone lost their mind why is that
well culture
okay yeah
oh yeah i think there's a lot of um like
even separating like art from the artist
a lot of biases as to what you'll accept
from one person and not accept from one
person and um
i think i also think a lot of people are
hypocrites i think a lot of people are
very quick to they say like those in
glass houses shouldn't throw stones and
i think a lot of people are very quick
to be like
especially in uk culture i know so many
people especially as kids would use gay
as a slur in the playground but then
they literally will act as though they
never did and it's like
but ah it's oh there's so many
intersections of this of like power
privilege race like there's so many
intersections but i think a lot of
people are glory hunters i think a lot
of people will say things and do things
to be woke or better than and i'm like
yeah but i don't know enough about like
the actual situation
to be like oh but
it depends on who he killed like if he
killed a [ __ ] like
white woman that was doing all this
charity work then there'd be uproar
if he's killing someone who is
considered or who's it
that way yeah no who's in i would say
it's because they're involved in that
life and it's kind of a choice like it's
kind of it's weird like
it's almost seen as like different live
by the sword die by the sword yeah yeah
i don't get it i'm like i would choose a
different hobby i don't know
um
you think of one no question yeah
um you can make it as
hard as you like hard as i like yeah
um
do you think that
oh have you ever given a girl dating
advice and it got led her astray
that it was like completely wrong advice
yeah
or or have you ever had a client that
you just thought was like bad [ __ ] crazy
you're like i can't there's no advice i
can give to you to help you because it's
just
because it's just who you are
uh
no one's it no one's ever lost course
uh no i've never per se
no i've never i've never thought
anyone's lost cause i've never given
advice where it's gone all right no no
if it's gonna rise usually because they
didn't take my advice
do you think most girls listen to your
advice
uh if they're paying me yes
if they're just asking me
because i have a lot of female friends
which is fine because that's what i'm
there for and i enjoy talking about it i
mean you know
um but i do have one or two
that they keep coming to me and
i've been telling the same thing for
like six to 12 months
and then it's just got to a point i'm
like you have to stop paying me because
i'm just saying the same thing over and
over at this point yeah do you know what
i mean
huh
no i have